hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that took place two days ago
uh when magnus was playing some chess 24
premium users and here he's facing
uh a user named tiger dagger or or
tigger diego
i couldn't really understand what it was
so i entered it in google and the google
said that this was actually norwegian
for chewing gum
and uh i dare you to try and pronounce
this on norwegian so we're just going to
refer to him as mr mr gum
or you know td or i don't know we'll see
how it goes
uh but it's a really exciting game it's
a really wild opening and uh
well something you don't know from the
thumbnail you do know that of course it
is the bonk
cloud but you do not know that uh it is
already as of move two
uh yes that we have a completely new
game so let's see
what's what's this all about uh so here
uh mr
uh mr chewing gum uh opens with f3 and
this is nothing out of the ordinary this
is a blitz game three plus zero
and uh you know such things will often
happen and i've just realized something
is wrong with the interface so let me
just uh
try and fix that there we go uh so yeah
he opens with f3 and
magnus okay says uh he will reply with
e5 makes sense your opponent doesn't
uh capture the center so you want to
capture the center with your own pawn
a very principled reply to f3 and here
of course king to f2
is a very very uh common idea
but instead of this white goes for h4
uh and this is already a new move uh so
already as of move two we have a
completely new game
and probably uh uh uh uh
a tiger digger or tiger tiger uh wanted
to achieve a new game already has a move
to that's why he chose this idea and his
plan is now to play king to f2 and have
this sort of a bomb cloud setup
with the h4 on the board for those of
you who are maybe new to chess
if you have a position like this never
play g for because then black can
deliver checkmate in in
already on the second move and uh if you
if you didn't notice
only black can deliver checkmate in two
moves for white to deliver checkmate it
will take at least
three moves so instead after e5 of
course we have
h4 and now magnus just continues in a
principled matter he grabs hold of the
center
uh he plays d5 and now he controls all
of these nice central squares
we have king to f2 the bomb cloud is now
fully operational
and magnus continues developing with
bishop the c5 with
check with e3 blocking check and now the
immediate d4
are getting ready to capture here with
check white will be unable to capture
because then you you hang the queen
so bishop to d3 uh and now a magnus just
continues uh
grabbing more space with f5 you could
capture but
now it's not a problem because the queen
is not in danger so instead after this
we have f5 and now knight the e2 white
just continues development like nothing
is really happening with knight to f6
uh and now not allowing any knights to
h5
ideas then you get control of f4 in g3 y
just pushes
h5 uh with e4 by magnus now getting
ready to
completely bust open the position he can
even castle here bring the rook to the
df file that is soon to open up so
bishop to c4
white prevents magnus from castling and
now knight to c6
uh we have e capture sunday for knight
captures on d4 and now white has to be
very careful
uh because here if tiger digger goes for
something like i don't know
uh anything other than moving the king
then just moving this knight
results in in just chaos that's uh
no no way to play chess so king to f1
was played
and now e captures an f3 we have g
captures and knight captures on f3
and again it's a very difficult position
for white not
a lot of moves available here uh the the
pieces will just continue piling up
so here white decides to give up a pawn
and
get at least some development in but it
also means that he now has to go into an
end game
uh without queens and he will will will
suffer for the rest of the game
so let's see how he does this he plays
d4 now uh he gives up on he will be able
to
uh develop the bishop open up his
position a little bit and
try and survive this so magnus captures
it of course the knight captures on d4
we have knight captures and
queen captures on d4 now offering to
trade queens but also if white isn't
careful
let's say you play something well
there's really nothing to play here but
let's say
play something like this which is super
weird queen to f2 will be checkmate
so instead after this queen captures on
d4 we have queen captures on d4
goes for a queen trade bishop captures
and now
knight to d2 now white continues
development uh but the problem is he's
down two pawns which against magnus is
quite a lot
so bishop to d7 magnus wants to shift
his bishop to this diagonal
and then his bishop pair will definitely
be fully operational
knight to f3 now just attacking the
bishop on d4 and now
just bishop to c6 and here uh your
knight is under attack if you move the
knight you'll lose the rook so
i remove like rook to h3 is possible but
then black just continues developing
castles rook e8 and his position is just
amazing he's still up to pawn so instead
after this bishop to c6 we have knight
captures on d4
sacrificing the exchange but for some
very interesting counter play magnus
grabs the rook and now
knights the e6 and this not only
prevents black from castling
but also attacks g7 and c7 so magnus
needs to do something about this
and he could play king to d7 it's not a
problem defend his spawn
but instead he goes knight captures on
h5 he grabs yet another pawn
uh allows white to play knight captures
and c7 and
to deliver check with a nice fork under
rook on a8 so here knight captures on c7
with check
king to d7 and now knight captures an a8
with rook captures on a8 and now king to
f2 again
going for the for the bong cloud square
we have king to c6
and now uh white again needs to continue
developing so
bishop to h6 and now you can't really
capture this bishop if the bishop is
captured then
uh the pawn structure is completely
ruined the knight still occupies the h
uh file and then if rook captures it you
know it's just gonna be
uh easy uh food for for the rook to
gobble up so instead after bishop to h6
magnus goes back with the bishop
we have bishop to d5 and now we have
bishop captures king captures and the
bishop to g5
we have h6 by magnus now rook to h1 uh
going after the knight but now magnus
says
i don't need to be up so many pawns i
can give one back and this is still
going to be a winning end game for me so
here
we have h captures and g5 we have rook
captures on h5
uh and now king the e5 getting ready to
defend to defend this pawn
king captures on g5 and now king to f6
now the rook needs to go back we have
rook to h5
and now of course rook the c8 bringing
the rook into the game
and here magnus is up only one pawn but
the
two connected pass pawns on the king
side are just so so dangerous so here we
have c3 not allowing to capture the c
pawn uh we have a5 by magnus and now a4
uh stopping any b5 counter play so rook
to c4
magnus just goes after the a4 pawn and
now king to e3 magnus grabs it with rook
captures on a4
and now rook to h8 white needs to try
to create some sort of a defensive setup
but it's not going to be easy rookie for
check we have king to f3 and now b6
we have rook to f8 with check king to g5
and now
rook to f7 so of course you're not going
to give up the pawn g6 we have rook back
to f8 and now
rook to e5 we have c4 by white
and now rook to c5 defending the pawn we
have b3 and now just
b5 busting open the position completely
rook to a8 going after the a5 pawn but
now just b
captures and c4 b captures rook captures
and rook captures on a5 and now magnus
is up
uh two very clean pawns here and it's
not going to be very difficult
to convert this we have rook to c3 with
check king goes back we have king to e2
now king to g4
now of course any checks are pretty much
pointless you're just going to block
with the pawn
so rook to d5 and now g5 of course we
rook to d4 with check f4 and now king to
d2
attacking the rook but now magnus just
plays rook to e3
and here uh uh the integra digger who
was uh uh
thinking about the position for some 10
seconds but then uh it was in this
position on mu45 that he decided to
resign the game as there is nothing more
to be done here
and he has some 20 seconds on the clock
and really
if you try to pronounce this in
norwegian it's just impossible
it's like you know complete sorcery be
careful not to summon something
um so yeah like i said uh here uh he
resigned and another excellent victory
for magnus
and even though this was a blitz game
you can see how uh even though uh
it's magnus was playing he still
couldn't completely crush
uh white when going for the bomb cloud
especially this super
super improved bomb cloud with f3 king
f2 and h4
so you can see it it does have its
merits but here uh white just couldn't
get
anything going and it was just a a
pretty pretty one-sided game
so for those of you who like me to
finish the games uh maybe are new to
chess
there's no point in white continuing
this because the rook prevents the king
from
even approaching those past pawns and
the the rook alone
uh will not be able to do all that much
to give you an example if something like
rook d5
you're gonna move the rook so you can
start pushing the pawn because the king
would just grab the rook so
rook anywhere doesn't really matter and
if rook to d3 now you just start pushing
f3
if d for check king g3 if you go after
the pawn just g4
there's nothing for white to do the king
cannot approach it cannot cross the e
file
and that's it rook d3 you're just gonna
move the king whatever you're just gonna
play this
this this and then you're gonna bring a
queen into the game and that's it
whatever white plays just
f1 queen and now we're gonna easily
checkmate the the white king
so after this rook the e3 move uh mr
hoodie guy here tigger digger resigned
the game uh and uh what uh what a a very
nice victory for for magnus carlsen
indeed
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank uh
aaron kottel uh
reza emanuel david walter and
george uh chatzi giorgio for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day